Trey,
my daddy Joe Rogan podcast by night,
all day.
That's what I know them.
Then you can't lie to me.
There's nothing you're going to lie to me about because if you lie to me,
I'm gonna see you on Monday,
idiot,
and we're going to see what you're made up anyway.
I mean,
without even knowing what they're made of,
you'll know their lines,
but it's different when you fight somebody,
you literally know what they're made of.
When you see the look in their eye and they say what they say and they do what
they do,
and then they go and they fight and they don't say what they say and they don't
do what they do.
And that's just fighting.
And that's what's so refreshing about it to me.
Yeah.
Well the psychological aspect of it,
I mean,
you know,
well,
who was it that said this fighting is 90% mental and the other 10% in your head?
I forgot who said that.
I remember either,
but I heard it.
That's a great quote.
I remember who said it,
but I read it.
I believe it with all my heart.
There's so many people out there,
there's so incredibly physically talented.
And how many Jim assassins do you know that for whatever reason they just can't
put it together when the referee says fine or are you ready finery ready to go?
They just are a fraction of who they really are.
Just really break down and think about what happens to the ones that do make it
and then have to deal with the media and uh,
opinions.
And I really feel like athletes,
the biggest hurdle is effect.
That we're willing to actually just get up there and say we might when we might
lose.
And just put that out there and say,
are you willing to,
to put yourself out there like that.
Are you willing to embarrass yourself if you do lose,
are you willing to deal with the media?
If you win for 10 years straight and then lose and then now you're the worst guy
that's ever been seen in the sport or the worst female that's ever been seen the
sport,
you didn't even belong there.
Are you able to deal with that?
That's the question.
That's what being an athlete is not,
well those would be an fighter being different strains to basketball game.
It's true.
You lose a basketball game and people might think you're a fucking loser or a
scrub,
but it's nothing like the shit that I see fighters face online.
No,
I mean,
just look at,
I gotta bring Ronda Rousey up because it's heartbreaking for me as an athlete.
I know what she's feeling,
I know what she's going through.
And um,
as a female it's even on another level,
I can't really imagine that.
I just,
it's a different level of scrutiny I would imagine.
But um,
it's just,
it shows how hard it is to deal with this man like the,
the ups and downs because the downs hit hard just as hard as it out to hit and
you gotta be ready and there can't be any separation and who you are with a win
and a loss.
Because if there is,
it's going to show and you gotta be who you are and not be solely connected to
fighting as your whole being.
Otherwise you're over when you,
when it,
when it ends.
Right.
That was something about the Ronda Rousey promos that I always felt like I just,
I didn't like hearing it.
Like she was like,
I gotta get back to fighting because it's the most important thing and it's a
thing that I can be best in the world.
And I was like,
Ooh,
I actually like hearing that studio.
I do.
And the reason is,
it's such a lesson if you really listening in between the lines to the issue of
the world.
And that's just my opinion.
We're all putting so much into this one thing and we think that that is our
everything when really if she,
Eh,
it sounds cheesy,
but if you put all that energy towards loving yourself and not the fight career,
the fight career will still be there just as heavy as it is.
Right.
You know?
So what I mean is she's using the fighting as her identity with that
championship belt.
She is Ronda Rousey,
the Ronda Rousey without the championship belt.
We don't know who she is.
She won't come out.
So who are you?
Unless you're winning?
We don't know.
Do you know you're counting on that belt to know who you are now and that's,
that was my biggest point.
That was a hurdle I ran into when I lost my belt.
I didn't know who I was anymore,
and that's how I knew this.
That's how I figured out what my issues were.
[inaudible]
yeah.